Bonjour!
Ça fait un petit moment depuis le dernier
Chroniques de Prof, alors pour ce retour on
va faire quelque chose d'exceptionnel: on
va parler exclusivement du XXe siècle.
-Intérieurement je suis en joie.
-Et pourquoi ne pas en avoir parlé plus tôt
effectivement? Vous m'avez déjà suggéré
des sujets qui s'y rapportent en commentaire
mais il se trouve que je suis médiéviste
de formation et que de toutes les périodes,
l'histoire contemporaine reste celle qui m'attire
le moins.
-Eh ouais. Un point pour le Moyen Âge.
-Mais là, il y a ce petit sujet qui me trottait
dans la tête depuis un moment et auquel j'ai
décidé de m'intéresser: l'aéropostale.
-Dis plutôt que la cyberhistorienne t'as
commandé un épisode dessus.
-Si vous n'avez pas compris la réplique précédente
je vous invite à regarder Time Warp, la fiction
que j'ai écrite, disponible sur cette chaîne!
Et sans plus attendre, envolons-nous!
Tout commence durant la Première Guerre Mondiale,
dans les usines de Pierre-Georges Latécoère.
Il s'agit d'un industriel toulousain qui possède
pas mal d'usines, qui produisent entre autres
du matériel de cantine, de voie ferrée,
du bois, etc. Effort de guerre oblige, le
ministère de l'armement lui demande de reconvertir
ses usines pour produire des munitions et
obus. En 1917, on lui passe commande de mille
avions Salmson 2A alors qu'il n'a jamais vu
d'avion de sa vie. Il démarche des experts,
fait agrandir ses locaux, il est super motivé.
Les premiers modèles sont prêts à être
livrés en octobre 1918 mais patatra: la
guerre se termine un mois plus tard. Bon,
ça c'est quand même plutôt positif.
-Et surtout, ça n'arrête pas Latécoère
qui est déter.
-C'est décidé, il veut faire carrière dans
l'aéronautique et a déjà une idée de reconversion:
une ligne de transport de courrier et de passagers.
Son initiative n'est pas nouvelle-nouvelle:
l'US Air Mail Service existe déjà, l'Italie
et l'Autriche ont aussi des premières lignes
régulières mais uniquement européennes.
Latécoère a un parcours bien précis en
tête: le Maroc, où 80 000 européens sont
installés «grâaace» à la colonisation,
l'Afrique Australe, et l'Amérique du Sud.
Toutes ces destinations échangent à l'époque
pas mal de courrier avec l'Europe mais avec
des délais très longs: 7 à 11 jours pour
le Maroc, 17 jours pour le Brésil, 23 pour
l'Argentine.
-Ce n'est pas le Pérou.
-Dès le 11 novembre, parce qu'il a pas le
temps, Latécoère dépose les statuts de
la CEMA: Compagnie Espagne, Maroc, Algérie.
Dès lors il étudie les routes possibles,
réadapte les Salmson qu'il avait produits
pour leur nouvel emploi, et se lance dans
une bataille administrative avec la France
et surtout l'Espagne qui n'est pas follement
emballée à l'idée de se faire survoler.
Le premier vol vers Barcelone a lieu le 25
décembre 1918, puis après quelques échecs
il atterrit le 8 mars 1919 à Rabat et offre
au maréchal Lyautey, qui dirige le protectorat
du Maroc, un journal daté de la veille et
un bouquet de violettes de Toulouse pour sa
femme.
-Parce que ça montre qu'il est rapide. Malin.
-C'est un gros succès, le maréchal encourage
le secrétariat d'Etat à l'Aéronautique
de signer le contrat avec Latécoère. À
partir du 1er septembre 1919, les lignes Latécoère
doivent effectuer huit vols mensuels entre
Toulouse et Rabat avec un surcoût postal
de 1,25 francs par courrier.
En 1919, l'aviation est populaire. Les aviateurs
se sont battus et sont reconnus pour leurs
exploits durant la guerre mais peu envisagent
un avenir pour l'aviation maintenant que la
paix est revenue: le civil ou le commercial,
bof. Les avions sont encore trop peu fiables
et tombent souvent en panne. La France possède
le plus grand parc volant avec environ 2000
appareils, mais l'heure est plutôt aux exploits,
les pilotes font des cascades, battent des
records...
Latécoère recrute justement ces pilotes
pour son nouveau projet. Parmi eux on trouve
Didier Daurat, ancien combattant super motivé.
L'entreprise connaît aussi ses premières
victimes: six aviateurs trouvent la mort
en 1920, cinq autres en 1921, une trentaine
d'avions sont déjà endommagés à cette
date. Pendant longtemps l'équipement reste
sommaire: les instruments de mesure ne sont
pas fiables, le premier vol avec radio a lieu
en 1923 mais elles ne se généralisent que
bien plus tard. La ligne coûte aussi plus
cher que ce qu'elle rapporte, mais Latécoère
reste motivé. Il rebaptise son entreprise
CGEA, pour Compagnie Générale d'Entreprises
Aéronautiques, mais doit au passage vendre
quelques unes de ses autres usines pour rentrer
dans ses frais. Il cherche à produire un
nouvel avion plus performant, et se penche
sur son nouvel objectif: l'Afrique Australe.
Il recrute pour cela le pilote Joseph Roig
et l'envoie en janvier 1923 en bateau pour
une mission de reconnaissance entre le Maroc
et Dakar. Pour cela il doit tisser des liens
avec deux enclaves espagnoles qui pourraient
devenir des aéroplaces d'étape, Cap-Juby
et Villa Cisneros. La distance totale entre
Casablanca est de 2760km, avec des étapes
de 600km de long. Une mission aérienne a
lieu en mai 1923: deux des avions échouent,
celui de Roig atteint Dakar après 22h de
vol.
Mais niveau problèmes techniques et géopolitique,
c'est toujours pas gagné.
-Le bilan de la CGEA en 1923 est pourtant
pas mal: un aller-retour quotidien entre
Toulouse et Casablanca, une nouvelle bretelle
vers Oran, 1344 passagers embarqués et trois
millions de lettres.
-En 1925 la ligne Casablanca-Dakar ouvre enfin,
et très vite y est affecté un nouveau pilote
qui devient par la suite une légende: Jean
Mermoz.
Jean Mermoz obtient son brevet de pilote en
1920 après trois tentatives: une première
où il se fracture la jambe et la mâchoire,
une deuxième deux jours plus tard où son
avion se retourne à l’atterrissage, et
enfin la bonne. Il est ensuite affecté en
tant que militaire à Palmyre où il réalise
son premier exploit: après que son moteur
ait pris feu, il traverse le désert durant
quatre jours en portant son mécanicien sur
ses épaules.
-Badass.
-Pourtant une fois à la CGEA, le gars décrit
sa vie simplement: «Nous accomplissons
simplement un métier, parfois un peu plus
dur que les autres, mais qui n'en est pas
moins un métier».
-En 1926 une autre figure célèbre rejoint
la ligne: Antoine de Saint-Exupéry, affecté
à l'aéroplace de Cap-Juby en 1927. Il passe
dix-huit mois là bas, se baladant dans le
désert à la rencontre des Maures et se liant
d'amitié avec Mermoz qui fait étape chez
lui à chaque vol. Le boulot reste difficile
pou les pilotes: les pannes sont fréquentes,
et entraînent même le risque de se faire
capturer par les tribus Maures de la Région.
La ligne vers Dakar est ouverte, il est donc
temps pour Latécoère de penser plus loin!
Dès 1924 il commande une reconnaissance vers
le Brésil, l'Uruguay et l'Argentine, et s'allie
avec l'industriel Bouilloux-Lafont pour mener
à bien son projet. Le défi est avant tout
technique: il s'agit de traverser les Andes,
avec des appareils à peine assez performants
pour ça. Le Laté 26 est mis en service en
1927 et permet d'envisager la chose.
C'est Guillaumet, un nouveau pilote qui devient
le principal artisan de la ligne des Andes,
qui tente le coup en 1928. Il réussit son
premier vol dans la nuit du 16 au 17 avril
mais les journaux considèrent alors qu'il
a juste eu de la chance.
-Puis il réussit de nouveau pendant une tempête.
-Mermoz se dit alors qu'il tenterait bien
aussi la chose, en passant par le Nord. Il
décolle le 2 mars 1929 avec son mécanicien
Collenot et le pilote de La Vaulx. Pas de
bol, leur moteur s'arrête: ils se posent
sur une plate-forme à 1500m, Mermoz est obligé
de sauter de l'avion et de s'accrocher à
une roue pour freiner l'appareil qui commençait
à tomber dans le vide.
-Ensuite, après 1h30 de réparations, ils
n'ont plus qu'à remonter l'avion tout le
long de la pente puis le lancer dans le vide
pour repartir. Audaces Fortuna Juvat.
Le 9 mars il retente le coup avec Collenot,
et c'est encore pire: l'avion devient incontrôlable
alors qu'il tente de passer un col et s'écrase
sur les rochers. Comme il ne semble pas réparable,
Mermoz et Collenot partent à pied par -20°C
mais constatent qu'ils ont peu de chances
de survie.
-Ils retournent donc à l'avion et passent
environ 50h à le réparer à coups de chiffons,
de fils de fer et de scotch.
-Il leur faut ensuite plusieurs heures pour
remonter l'avion en haut de la pente, et enfin
le lancer dans le vide, le faire rebondir
sur les trois plate-formes qui prolongent
la piste, et enfin arriver au Chili. Leur
exploit fait de Mermoz une célébrité de
l'aviation. Il montre ensuite le chemin emprunté
à Guillaumet, qui assure la liaison hebdomadaire
à partir du 15 juillet 1929. Saint-Exupéry
est envoyé en Amérique du Sud la même année:
le groupe de pilotes est installé à Buenos
Aires pour quelques années d'exploits ordinaires.
L'aéropostale fonctionne, il faut désormais
quatre jours et demi pour qu'un courrier passe
de la France au Chili.
«Ce que nous avons fait, Dabry, Gimié
et moi, d'autres le feront bientôt. Nous
eûmes simplement l'honneur d'être les premiers
désignés pour mener à bien cette tentative.
Nous n'avons fait que parcourir une des étapes
de la Ligne Europe-Amérique du Sud».
Guillaumet réalise un autre exploit en 1930.
Il décolle le vendredi 13 juin de Santiago
pour son trajet habituel, mais le temps est
mauvais. Il est contraint d'atterrir au milieu
des Andes, passe deux jours sur place en attendant
que la tempête passe. Le dimanche, l'avion
de recherches envoyé pour le retrouver ne
le voit pas. Il écrit alors sur le fuselage
de son appareil «N'ayant pas été repéré
par l'avion, je pars vers l'est. Adieu à
tous. Ma dernière pensée sera pour ma femme».
Du dimanche au jeudi, il marche, à travers
les Andes et la neige, rapidement pieds nus.
Il parcourt soixante kilomètres avant d'être
retrouvé près de Mendoza, en Argentine.
En 1930 l'Aéropostale transporte plus de
300 voyageurs entre la France et l'Argentine,
réalise 27 millions de francs de recettes
par an, et transporte 32 millions de lettres.
Elle s'effondre l'année suivante, à la suite
du krach boursier de 1929. Elle est mise en
liquidation judiciaire, même si les vols
continuent, et est rachetée en 1933 par Air
France. Le matériel est moins bien entretenu,
les anciens avions sont envoyés à la casse.
-Les pilotes aussi.
-Oui, les pilotes qui ont fait la légende
de la ligne disparaissent: Collenot le premier,
le 10 février 1936. Mermoz dit de lui:
«Collenot n'aurait dû disparaître qu'avec
moi. La fatalité n'a pas été juste en divisant
cet équipage.» Guillaumet veut démissionner,
mais ça lui est refusé. Mermoz s'engage
dans les Croix de Feu, un mouvement nationaliste
proche du fascisme, bien que Saint-Exupéry
tente de l'en dissuader. Il disparaît également
en vol le 7 décembre 1936. La Seconde Guerre
Mondiale a raison des autres: Guillaumet
le suit en 1940, lors d'un vol Marseille-Beyrouth;
Saint-Exupéry tombe au large de Marseille
en 1944. Son avion a été retrouvé en 2003.
«Pourquoi nous l'aimons, notre ligne?
[Disait Guillaumet] C'est parce qu'elle vit.
Elle vit de tout ce que nous lui avons donné
de nous-mêmes. Quand elle a débuté, nous
étions dix-huit jeunes voués à son succès,
de toute notre âme. De ces dix-huit, nous
sommes quarante aujourd'hui et tous ceux qui
manquent sont morts à leur poste, en pleine
lutte, pour que la Ligne vive. (…) Vous
comprenez bien que, pour nous, leurs voix
ne se sont pas tues. Elles commandent!»
Merci d'avoir regardé cet épisode, si vous
l'avez apprécié vous pouvez toujours le
partager, le commenter, ou faire un don sur
Tipeee ou Utip qui sont les deux plate-formes
qui me permettent de financer mes vidéos.
Je vais essayer de retrouver un rythme un
peu plus soutenu en cette année 2020, alors
en attendant la prochaine vidéo je vous remercie
d'être toujours plus nombreux par ici et
à bientôt!